pour ce message d' emmanuel macron lu en
direct donc vous le vous l'avez entendu
sur france 24 à l'assemblée nationale
par richard ferrand le président de
l'assemblée nationale je me tourne vers
vous roselyne febvre bonjour
le président français qui parle d'un
tournant majeur avec cette guerre en
ukraine tournant majeur qui aura des
conséquences sur la vie des français il
prévient qu'il y aura peut-être des
moments difficiles notamment à cause des
sanctions économiques prises contre la
russie oui il l'avait déjà dit hier
lorsqu'il avait dit ce sera un tournant
pour l'europe et pour la france et je
vais protéger les françaises qui
n'étaient pas de nature à en tout cas à
rassurer il ya trois messages dans ce
que vient de dire le président a concédé
un an ne va rien céder de les sanctions
pour les pour les russes et les
oligarques et l'entourage de poutine
sera elles seront fortes et 3 la
solidarité avec le cren et notamment
avec un matériel défensif qui sera livré
voilà l'idée du président de la
république eh bien cette adresse aux
parlementaires
c'est en quelque sorte recherché aussi
mais il n'aura pas besoin j'imagine mais
là l'unité nationale parce qu'il est
vrai que depuis quelques semaines déjà
autour de la de la russie et du raid
diplomatique si je peux parler comme ça
de ce qu'avait entrepris emmanuel macron
il y avait eu beaucoup de critiques
notamment de l'opposition
c'est donc voilà assez de chercher en
tout cas de la part des parlementaires
de l'opposition à la fois un soutien une
union nationale et aussi
voilà une reste une forme de
responsabilité est ce qu'on n'a pas
toujours vu du côté des de certains
candidats à la présidentielle